I really really love museums so last
week I organized something got together
a bunch of other youtubers like me and
we went on a museum crawl a pub crawl is
where you go from pub to pub in a town
drinking each establishment before
moving on to the next and museum crawl
is exactly the same but instead of
drinking you're learning man that sounds
way less cool out loud
we started at the Science Museum who had
given us tickets to their special
exhibition on the Sun and they even let
us in before public opening hours
museums with other people perfect so
right now we're in the Sun exhibit at
the Science Museum around beautiful
sunrise honestly this whole trip was
organized kinda it's easy to just see
cool stuff like this this is an aura
room not just any honoree this is the
very first one so the idea is that if
you turn the crank and the moon move
around the Sun at the correct ratio and
relative motion this is the very first
one name is an artery because it was
made for I always thought it was just a
scientific term apparently not
you do look a bit like a substitute
language teacher right now it's really
good tracking everyone's filming not
having a museum crawl
[Music]
alright see ya
[Music]
if you're in London this is an
absolutely amazing exhibition we were
just moving around solar panels to try
and power at our Hannah and Sian were
just predicting solar storms this is a
really really cool
[Music]
okay exhibit one done so after the Sun
exhibit we're now having a quick look
around the rest of the Science Museum
this was new to me this hasn't been here
for a while I went to a talk in Oxford
the engineer's talking about how they
were going to build these engines these
are sabre engines and that's a Skylon
space ball as a single-stage-to-orbit
super super cool space plane concept
which they're still working I was there
when they were talking about this we're
about to end lisanna on Berkut and she's
gone gift shops for something of a theme
for the day keep an eye on Hannah anyway
after the science museum we had a nice
little lunch and then we went on to
museum number two so Science Museum's
done we just had a very you know
Hannah's down there yeah pretty nice
lunch now Office of Museum number two of
the day the V&A
[Music]
oh man look about juicy rump what do
they have at the V&A I think that looks
like Trajan's column in ace by the way
is here you've got a fiver date so good
best of luck on the 21st of January yeah
Saint aneesa's day turns out hopefully
dr. anis day as well like Instagram is
sketchy
this is so cool this feels like an
Oxford College right in the middle of
the VNA there's just this huge quad
ignored ignore me details
so I've tracked everybody into the
Japanese section quickly before we leave
the VNA because there's a youtuber that
I've been obsessed with for the past
year or two called david bull David
Seung who does Japanese woodblock prints
and I've watched everything he's ever
made and I've now learned a lot about
his prints and I just want to see some
genuine ones from the era in the flesh
[Music]
Simon because you're new to the channel
everybody both Hannah and Ernie
submitted videos now what is your
channel what do you do so my channel
books and whales it's a lot of books as
you might assume there's also some
university advise career advice I used
to work on publishing now freelancer
some travel Ellen that squeaky noise
some travel across the UK museum things
like this can I culture and books and
sometimes book two films
after extracting Hannah from gift shop
we then made our way to the place I've
been looking forward to all day one of
my favorite places in the entire world
the Natural History Museum in London I
like to make it known that we don't
actually have to go up this
I'll let you buy one thing later and go
to the exhibition now so there are two
exciting things happening in the natural
history museum today the first of which
is the life in the dark exhibit we've
been given press tickets which in the
words of full of really contemplate the
amazing this is such a cool exhibit it's
really some atmospheric and here very
very well put together but at the top
you still got the normal architecture of
the Natural History Zoo
while I'm about to walk into
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like big expanses of deep ocean for me
for all of these critters
[Music]
90% of marine animals make their own
[Music]
so what do we think of the life in the
dart exhibit guys in affectation
why don't you insects not enough that
could have been warm I know you hated
the sea life but you have to admit it's
pretty cool no no it's not but wait
there's more because we're being shown
around well just just wait a sec so if
you come to London and you don't go to
the Natural History Museum then you are
a fool
because goddamn blue whale in there a
Treo beautiful museum of science anyway
I also love it there we have however got
a rush because because we're on the way
to the Attenborough centre thank you for
the segue Hanna because we've been taken
behind the scenes to have a look at some
tanks
[Music]
no one has a magical table that's gonna
briefing so laughter mm-hmm
no no wait here so floor to ceiling all
the way from if you look behind you
there's just another simple lab behind
there that everything going forward
towards the tank room is all part of the
plexi stuff
[Music]
you look at this one just here we have
two of the extent of living fishes we
have raping fishes and loaves and fishes
99% our ray-finned fishes they can feel
the spines the color difference you see
two more jars leach out at the time
[Music]
in terms of that to their sturgeon so
they're all together yep so if you
lifted up one of these this is what it
look like we've got a angler fish I can
see the stingray just here on the shaft
doing it to it like I was for you guys
and I standing that camera those doors
just opened up and this mid-high just
flying through the air it was actually
on the harness but you couldn't see the
harness its tongue was hanging out and
all the people on the tour just looked
at me and said is this normal am i this
is definitely not normal it's called
Archie it is
nicknamed Archie because it's
opportunist that's the Latin name for it
know your name
this was accidentally caught in the off
the Falkland Islands in 2004 it came to
us completely in a block block of ice
you can imagine the smell when I was
defrosting and they said they could
smell from the 7th floor this because it
has taken twice as long as we thought it
would because all of us are just
thinking what's that but yeah these are
all specimens collected by down
genuinely thank you so much to the
lovely people of the museums in
particular
Aisling and Freya for organizing the
stuff at the naturist Museum and the
Science Museum respectively and today
for the amazing tank tour also of course
thank you for watching the video if you
enjoyed it which I hope you did then pop
in a like but also pop along to the
museum's that we visited all the places
that we visited in this vlog are free to
visit in London and I think they're
awesome so check em out if you have a
museum near you they'd like to recommend
it you think I should check out then pop
that down in the comments because
there's nothing better than museum
tourism for now though I've got to go as
a matter of fact I'm off to Exeter one
last time because I need to collect my
PhD I'll see at the graduation
[Music]